gracias por acompañarnos en esta nueva
emisión de reporteros comenzamos la
república de maldivas en el sur de asia
compuesta por mil 190 islas de coral es
conocida por sus aguas cristalinas
playas de arena blanca y extensos
arrecifes
sin embargo sobre este archipiélago está
la amenaza constante de su desaparición
y los motivos el cambio climático y la
subida del nivel del mar al ritmo actual
de calentamiento global el 80 por ciento
de las maldivas podría volverse
inhabitable para 2050 el pico más alto
de este país no supera los 2,3 metros de
altitud los líderes de la isla llevan
mucho tiempo instando al mundo a actuar
según los objetivos de los acuerdos de
parís de 2015 allí estuvo nuestro
reportero albán álvarez quien hoy está
con nosotros y aprovecho para
preguntarle al van son las maldivas
respetuosas con el clima
cuando hablamos de las maldivas pensamos
en un lugar paradisíaco pero la realidad
es que el país tiene un gran problema
con el cambio climático y en especial
con la polución de plástico el manejo de
residuos no está implementado en el país
claramente la mayoría de la basura por
ejemplo es enviada a una isla artificial
y se ha convertido en una bomba tóxica
en medio del océano logramos acercarnos
a esta isla para realizar este reportaje
fosis fútbol invitados entonces a ver el
siguiente reportaje
[Música]
y este lugar era nuestro terreno de
juego era una playa hermosa
ahí era donde jugábamos fútbol cuando
éramos niños
cuando teníamos unos 10 años desde aquí
hasta el otro extremo estaba la playa y
donde estamos ahora era nuestro patio de
recreo
[Música]
janfar que le ha pasado toda su vida en
estos cuantos kilómetros cuadrados de
arena
y los ha visto consumirse
para proteger la playa construimos este
dique que le daba toda la vuelta a la
laguna ahora me doy cuenta hasta qué
punto este lugar se ha erosionado y
cuánta playa hemos perdido y eso me
entristece profundamente
desde hace varias décadas toulouse fue
una de las 1200 islas de las maldivas
está haciendo lentamente devorada por la
subida del nivel de las aguas y esta
erosión ahora amenaza a las tierras
cientos de palmeras que bordean la costa
han desaparecido
cada día un poco de estas tierras
desaparece llevada por las olas ahora
que ya no hay árboles ni palmeras sin
los árboles la playa ya no está
protegida lo que ahora queda aquí pronto
desaparecerá
mire es esta playa lo que ven en el
vídeo es en este lugar me gustaría que
volviera a ser como en este vídeo tengo
tantos buenos recuerdos aquí de este
lugar donde nos acostábamos bajo los
árboles la isla de toulouse es tan sólo
un ejemplo entre decenas de otros hubo
dura ocurrido pero nombres paradisíacos
pero estas islas ya desaparecieron del
mapa una emergencia climática y
humanitaria y una cuenta regresiva que
ya comenzó
a finales de 2009 a seis metros de
profundidad miembros del gobierno
maldigo realizaron el primer consejo
submarino de ministros de la historia a
través de esta sorprendente acción le
hicieron un llamado al mundo para que se
tomaran medidas drásticas contra el
cambio climático y contra el aumento del
nivel de los océanos que amenaza con
devorar se la república de las maldivas
este archipiélago situado en pleno
corazón del océano índico cuenta con 16
atolones 1200 islotes de arena
inmaculada situados a menos de un metro
por encima del nivel del mar al ritmo
actual 80% del archipiélago será
devorado para 2050 combinado con la
polución que diezma su excepcional
biodiversidad hoy en día las maldivas
son un paraíso con el tiempo contado
al norte de las maldivas la isla privada
de cura dura en el archipiélago cerca de
150 islotes son explotados por hoteles
de lujo como este por mucho tiempo
acusados de contribuir a la
contaminación del país varios lugares
turísticos han tomado en los últimos
años un viraje eco-responsable para
proteger sus lagunas
estos fragmentos de corales están vivos
y provienen de un cultivo los ubicamos
en esta estructura y crecerán ahí encima
luego establecerán su propia colonia y
en tres años con un poco de suerte este
marco estará lleno de corales
alejandra y mané son biólogas marinas
trabajar en asociación con este hotel en
un proyecto de trasplante de esquel es
de coral a estas estructuras
artificiales porque este pequeño animal
con esqueleto mineral podría contribuir
a salvar las maldivas cuando las olas
rompen contra las islas los corales
absorben su energía
entonces permiten proteger las islas de
la erosión
a causa del calentamiento de los océanos
hoy en día el 80% de los corales del
país se han visto diezmados
pero junto a estas villas de lujo
podrías por favor tomarle foto a los
corales
la esperanza parece renacer
esos corales transplantados provienen de
las especies más resistentes y
sobreviven a las corrientes calientes en
toda esta zona los corales parecen estar
saludables y podemos observar muchos
peces nadan a su alrededor porque los
corales los protegen y les proveen
alimento
esto nos llena de esperanza porque en
estos últimos años perdimos muchos
corales todo se blanquearon entonces si
esto realmente nos da esperanza y
alegría
[Música]
el complejo hotelero incluso sea equipo
con un centro de estudios marinos al
cual son enviados los datos que tan
moran un ingeniero francés elaboró para
este programa un software con tecnología
de punta inteligencia artificial para
vigilar el desarrollo cada cuadrado
indica que el computador ha detectado
automáticamente un coral entonces nos
dice qué especie detectó y en verde
aparecen los corales muertos hasta este
momento cuando queríamos analizar el
crecimiento de los corales era necesario
ir bajo el agua sumergirse con una
pizarra y anotar todas las colonias una
por una cuando los estudios se hacen de
esa manera se abarcan máximo unas
centenas de fragmentos y desde que
podemos analizar de manera automática
pasamos a otra escala por completo ahora
estamos analizando 70.000 colonias a la
vez pasar a otra escala es la decisión
que tomaron las maldivas para tratar de
proteger a sus habitantes
en la isla de male la capital cerca de
230 mil personas ya viven asignadas en
tan solo dos kilómetros cuadrados
entonces para resistir a la subida de
las aguas y para alojar a su creciente
población las autoridades decidieron
crear una isla 100% artificial
[Música]
un luma ley la ciudad de la esperanza en
vive y jacint kan es uno de los
arquitectos a cargo del proyecto lo que
hicimos es que creamos por completo esta
isla en un lugar donde antes sólo había
océano
y concebimos esta isla artificial a una
altura de 2 metros por encima del nivel
del mar
este proyecto titánico cobró vida en
2001 20 años después se construyó un
primer islote con zonas industriales y
residenciales 45 mil habitantes ya se
han mudado
[Música]
así acepto llevarnos hasta este lugar
todavía prohibido para el público para
descubrir el segundo islote de uno mal
en aquí deben surgir de la tierra un
barrio de negocios un puerto deportivo
una universidad y nuevos hoteles para
atraer más turistas
utilizamos esa arena para construir el
suelo de esta isla y de dónde viene esa
arena esa arena que sacamos del fondo
del mar
la construcción de un luma le necesitará
10 millones de metros cúbicos de arena
costo total 35 mil millones de dólares
de los cuales una parte han sido
financiados por china una manera de
reforzar su posición estratégica en el
océano índico
en todos los bloques de vivienda esos
edificios que están por allá son
inmuebles residenciales que vienen en
camino están en construcción
la segunda fase debería acoger cien mil
personas se podría decir que es una
ciudad entera
tulum ale debería estar terminada para
pero este proyecto para salvar a las
maldivas de un drama ecológico tiene
otro costo e irónicamente es ambiental
y crear desde cero unos terraplenes tal
vez no sean la única solución desde
ahora con la evolución de las
tecnologías podríamos imaginar cómo
hacer para que nuestra población viva
directamente sobre el agua
el terraplenado tiene sus aspectos
negativos perjudica a nuestros arrecifes
y el hábitat submarino
[Música]
y estas islas artificiales en las
maldivas no siempre son utilizadas
sabiamente
hasan baby creó hace 10 años la
asociación salvemos nuestras playas
lucha contra la contaminación ambiental
[Música]
ya dejaba aquí tenemos nuestra colecta
de plástico solo de este mes
todos los días después de haber limpiado
la playa si uno vuelve después de una
hora va a encontrar alguna cosa en la
orilla con seguridad
la mayor parte del tiempo es plástico
es una historia muy triste y por eso lo
he hecho desde hace diez años y no me
voy a detener
qué más se puede hacer tuve tantos
el plástico se encuentra en las playas
tengo la impresión
de que es un trabajo interminable
pero sobre todo en el océano
donde es ingerido por la fauna marina
contaminando toda la cadena alimenticia
pero baby quiere mostrarnos una de las
mayores batallas que enfrenta
situada a varios kilómetros en barco de
la capital la isla artificial de tila
fuji
nos dirigimos hacia el lugar donde
vierten la basura
o por dios
llamada la isla basura
y la fusión fue construida por el
gobierno para recibir los desechos que
provienen de todo el archipiélago una
montaña de basura desbordante por todas
partes
hay momentos en los que ni siquiera
pueden contener los incendios que se
desatan los desechos se queman a causa
de los gases nocivos en el interior pero
también en la superficie cuando la
excavadora mecánica recoge la basura
mucho se cae al agua hasta 400 toneladas
de desechos son vertidos cada día por
los barcos
[Música]
los productos nocivos que se liberan
contaminan los suelos y se esparcen por
el océano índico este no es el color de
nuestra laguna este color proviene de la
basura
[Música]
normalmente el agua de nuestra laguna es
turquesa
[Música]
todo el mundo es responsable el gobierno
no ha tomado ninguna medida no ha
buscado ninguna solución para el
problema de los desechos en las maldivas
y el sector de turismo algunas islas se
tratan de establecer un sistema de
tratamiento de sus desechos tratan de
hacerlo pero la mayoría de los demás
hoteles de lujo no lo hacen
[Música]
a pesar de los riesgos en las maldivas
siguen prosperando los proyectos de
islas artificiales
en todo el país e iniciado una carrera
contra el reloj
pero para las maldivas el reto es
también encargarse de sus propias
contradicciones
regresamos con albany álvarez autor del
reportaje que ustedes acaban de ver y le
pregunto el 80 por ciento de las mil 190
islas de coral de las maldivas están a
menos de un metro por encima del nivel
del mar como reaccionan los habitantes
de las maldivas ante la amenaza a la que
se enfrentan
conocimos varios activistas locales que
tratan de advertir a las autoridades y
educar a las nuevas generaciones una de
ellas es esa silla hit maestro de surf y
buceo quien trata de proteger sitios de
surfeo que están desapareciendo debido a
las murallas construidas para reducir el
impacto de la erosión
quiero tener un lugar en donde los niños
disfruten de buenas olas como nosotros
lo disfrutábamos antes es decepcionante
porque la gente que los destruye son
maldivos y deberían saber que están
destruyendo su propio hogar
es una vergüenza que cada año perdamos
parte de esta belleza debido a las
demandas de todo tipo de industrias
removiendo tierra para construir es
triste
el anterior presidente de las maldivas
de una conferencia de prensa bajo el
agua para señalar la amenaza que pesa
sobre las islas diez años después siguen
enfrentándose al mismo dilema
si es el mismo presidente de hace diez
años quien intentó crear un fondo
soberano para comprar tierras en un país
vecino como una póliza de seguro en
contra del cambio climático y salvar así
a los malditos del aumento del nivel del
mar pero esta idea nunca se ha llevado a
cabo nunca se ha implementado de hecho
es muy difícil comprar tierras de otro
país
una solución que ha llamado la atención
de las autoridades incluso de naciones
unidas es la creación de ciudades
flotantes sostenibles lo cual generaría
demasiados reclamos como vimos en el
reportaje es muy futurista pero otras
islas turísticas están usando pilotos
para soportar cabañas sobre el agua en
menor escala que soportar toda una
población
gracias al band por acompañarnos en esta
emisión de reporteros a ustedes también
gracias por estar con nosotros recuerde
que puede ingresar a nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para ver esta emisión
y las anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]